merci de d'avoir répondu à notre demande
d'audition euh il va nous falloir un
petit peu de méthode pour organiserre
débat mais je suis certain que avec
l'aide du rapporteur et de mes collègues
on arrivera
à solliciter vos vos connaissances sans
dépasser le le timing qu'on s'est
assigné euh on a une obligation de de
prestation de serment devant une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
puisque vous avez qu'un faux témoignage
serait passible de peines qui sont
prévus aux articles 434- 13-1- 15 du
code pénal et je vais donc au
préalable vous inviter à prêter servment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité à lever la main droite et à dire
je le jure on peut le faire
collectivement merci de
cette formalité ce que je vous propose
je sais pas comment vous l'avez organisé
entre vous peut-être un propos liminire
et puis ensuite on s'en remet au au jeu
des questions-réponses
madame de La Roche c'est tombé sur vous
c'est ça tout à fait bonjour monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et
messieurs au nom au nom du ministère des
Affaires étrangères déjà merci beaucoup
de nous avoir convié à à cette
commission d'enquête
aujourd'hui je commencerai par vous
présenter l'action du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères euh
dans le cadre en tout cas dans lequel
nous nous inscrivons la manière dont
nous travaillons avec l'interministériel
sur ces sujets euh et quelques quelques
grands axes de notre coopération
internationale en en matière de lutte
contre le le trafic de stupéfiant eu le
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères inscrit son action dans le
cadre des orientations qui sont fixées
par euh la mission interministérielle de
lutte contre les drogues et les
conduites addictives la 1000 des
cas et ces ces orientations stratégiques
sont bien entendu reprises dans le cadre
du du plan national de lutte contre les
stupéfiants pilotés par
l'ofast et le M ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères a naturellement
un rôle à jouer également dans la mise
en œuvre de ce plan puisque nous avons
une mesure qui nous est qui nous est
confié qui porte sur le renforcement de
la coopération internationale tant
bilatéral que multilatéral
pour donc en lien avec les pays de
transit de rebond
d'origine des de stupéfiants et qui sont
à destination du territoire national ou
de
l'Europe il s'agit donc de renforcer la
place de la lutte contre les stupéfiants
dans notre dialogue politique avec les
zones identifiées comme prioritaires
Amérique latine Balcans Afrique de
l'Ouest
ou des pays Émirats arabes unis Proche
et Moyen-Orient et donc de renforcer les
coopérations institutionnelle technique
et opérationnelle existant avec ces pays
désignés comme prioritaires alors
quelques mots sur notre action
multilatérale au niveau européen déjà
nous prenons une part active dans les
travaux qui sont mené au sein du Conseil
de l'Union européenne en premier lieu le
Conseil le groupe horizontal sal drogue
qui se réunit sur une base mensuelle la
mil
dek tient le tient le siège pour la
France et nous soutenons la mildk bien
évidemment et nous nous accompagnons les
travaux qui sont lancés par les
présidences successive portant sur la
réduction de l'offre et de la demande
des drogues et dans le cadre de la
Stratégie européenne
antidrogue et nous veillons également au
au suivi des discussions qui étaient en
qui ont été
lancé sous présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne il y a 2
ans notamment s'agissant de la
transformation de l'Observatoire
européen des drogues et toxicomanie en
une véritable agence et de plusieurs
problématiques telles que les drogues à
l'air du numérique l'impact
environnemental des drogues ou encore
les défis posés par la cocaïne
j'ajouterai que le suivi attentif de la
situation en Ukraine et l'impact que la
guerre en Ukraine a sur les trafics est
une préoccupation constante au niveau
européen la guerre semblant
effectivement avoir déplacer certains
itinéraires de trafic d'héroïne et de
cocaïne et pourrait à terme encourager
une production locale de drogue de
synthèse en outre nous participons au
dialogue entre l'Union européenne et des
États tiers euh on peut citer le Brésil
la
Colombie les états céac donc Amérique
latine Caraïbes et l'Asie centrale et
les
États-Unis au niveau
international de même la France suit les
travaux menés dans le cadre des
instances onusiennes de également de
l'ONUDC office des Nations Unies contre
la drogue et le crime qui est basé à
Vienne et nous suivons les travaux de la
commission des
stupéfiants la France s'efforce dans ses
enceintes de maintenir une position
d'équilibre qui comprend des efforts de
prévention des usages et de soins aux
dépendances dans le strict respect des
droits de l'homme et des conventions
internationales de contrôle des drogues
en effet on constate une polarisation
croissante dans toutes les enceintes et
y compris au niveau européen d'ailleurs
entre les pays ayant une approche
presque exclusivement répressive et ce à
l'autre extrémité du spectre qui prône
une une légalisation de la consommation
des drogues en premier lie lieu du
cannabis au nom du respect des libertés
individuelles nous veillons ainsi à à
préserver le cadre juridique
international existant et les les droits
de l'homme que certains pays cherchent à
relativiser Russie Iran
Chine à cet égard la la prochaine
session de la Commission des stupéfiants
qui se réunit en mars de cette année
sera une échéance importante elle
comprendra un segment de haut niveau
pour lequel nous nous chercherons à
obtenir une participation de de bon
niveau égal
avec une révision à mi-parcours
d'engagement prix dans le cadre d'une
déclaration ministérielle sur les
drogues de
2019 un autre volet de nos travail
concerne le maintien de l'influence
française dans toutes ses enceintes
international il y a des élections
prochainement pour renouveler le siège
de la France au sein de la commission
des stupéfiants que j'ai évoqué
également renouveler la nomination de
l'expert français au sein de l'organe
international de contrôle des stupéfiant
qui fait un petit peu figure de gardien
des traités
euh quelques exemples de d'initiative
internationale que nous que nous
soutenons au niveau du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
euh les États-Unis ont lancé en juillet
de l'an passé une coalition mondiale
contre les drogues de synthèse euh
essentiellement pour répondre à la crise
du fantanil euh qui qui cause plus de
100000 décès par an aux
États-Unis
le ministère a joué un rôle pour veiller
à ce que la France rejoigne pleinement
cette cette nouvelle
coalition parce que même si nous ne
sommes pas menacés au même titre que les
États-Unis le sont aujourd'hui la menace
néanmoins existe sur le territoire
national et nous faisons désormais
partie des 109 membres de la coalition
et nous prenons une part active dans
chacun des groupes de travail donc avec
l'interministériel bien entendu
s'agissant de la coopération que nous
avons avec les pays d' Amérique latine
et des Caraïbes j'ai mentionné les
dialogues UE CAC nous finançons
également en Bolivie désormais en en
Colombie des projets de développement
alternatif en lien avec des acteurs
privés pour donc remplacer les cultures
de de de coca par des des cultures de
café s'agissant de l'Afghanistan le
narcotrafic en provenance de ce pays se
maintient à des niveaux très élevés euh
l'AFAN an est source de plus de 80 % de
l'opium mondial et continue d'impacter
le territoire national et européen et ce
en dépit des décrets d'interdiction qui
ont été proclamé par le régime Taleb qui
ont certes fait chuter la production
annuelle dans le pays et et mener à des
destructions de stock très importantes
néanmoins on constate que les flux en
provenance de ce pays se maintiennent
les cisines demeurent très importante
et et il ne faut pas négliger le fait
que le pays dispose de stock très
importants et que pour le régime Taleb
la manne financière que les stupéfiants
représentent demeure très importante eu
et et et du reste nous constatons une
augmentation de la production de
métamphétamine dans le pays eu sur ce
sujet nous avons dressé le constat que
certains des outils dont disposait la
communauté internationale était
désormais inopérant pour diverses
raisons et nous menons une réflexion en
lien avec nos partenaires notamment du
G7 et avec l'ONUC pour voir comment nous
pouvons lutter efficacement contre
contre la menace en provenance
d'Afghanistan un mot sur le trafic de
captagon qui est une drogue
principalement produite en Syrie à
destination des pays du golf qui est en
croissance exponentielle et constitue
une menace à la stabilité de la région
et potentiellement au-delà si l'on
considère le fait que l'Europe est une
zone de rebond et qu'il y a déjà eu des
laboratoires démantelés euh chez
certains de nos voisins notamment aux
Pays-Bas sur ce sujet le ministère mène
à la fois des actions bilatérales de
renforcement des capacités avec des pays
partenaires de la zone également des
actions multilatérales euh en lien avec
l'onud
DC nous avons également contribué à
l'adoption de sanctions européennes pour
des individus et entités liées au trafic
de captagon il y a 1 an et nous comptons
bien utiliser encore ce levier
prement je m'arrêterai là puisque on
nous avait indiqué une intervention
liminaire entre 5 et 10 minutes et je
vous
remercie
euh mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur donc Jean-Noël
bonieux je suis sousd directeur pour la
zone Moyen-Orient
euh je ma zone de géographique de
compétence couvre l'Iran l'Irak et la
péninsule arabique et ce que je peux
vous dire en propos liminire sont les
choses suivantes on peut faire une
typologie de pays dans la zone que je
couvre avec des pays qui sont
traditionnellement des pays producteurs
alors l'Afghanistan n'est pas dans la
zone anmo dans la zone anmo on a trois
principaux prays producteurs qui sont la
Syrie évidemment devenu
pays producteur principal de captagon le
Liban
euh et l'Iran qui est un producteur très
significatif de de drogue de synthèse
cristal mamphétamine donc et seul l'Iran
seul de ces quatre pays seul l'Iran et
dans ma zone géographique de compétence
ensuite on a des pays qui étaient
traditionnellement des pays de transit
mais qui deviennent de plus en plus des
pays de consommation et ça c'est un
élément nouveau c'est que la
consommation domestique local se
développe de plus en plus dans les pays
suivants Irak kouwait Oman et Yémen
euh on peut je pourrais si ça vous
intéresse détailler les raisons de cette
évolution mais en tout cas la
consommation domestique se développe
dans ces pays et puis vous avez
enfin les pays de destination classique
qui sont l'Arabie à Saoudite et les
émirat arabe uni voilà voilà en quelques
mots comment la la région se divise euh
avec des des types de consommation qui
qui divergent en fonction des pays par
exemple dans les dans au sultanadoman et
au Yémen la consommation locale
estessenellement une consommation de
4 alors que en Arabie Saoudite et aux
Émirats c'est plutôt de la consommation
de captagon et de drogue de
synthèse en Irak aussi se développe de
plus en plus la consommation de captagon
en provenance de Syrie
voilà je peux vous dire quelques mots
sur les sur les proche de de ces pays en
terme de traitement du problème
euh d'abord le d'abord il y a une il y a
une prise de
conscience de plus en plus réelle des
autorités de ces pays sur le problème
que constitue la drogue qui est un
problème à la fois de sécurité mais
aussi évidemment un problème de santé
publique et évidemment un problème de
réputation également vous avez des pays
comme l'Iran où la consommation de
drogue selon nos chiffre est très
importante avec 3 % de la population qui
consomme de la drogue en Iran ce qui
fait à peu près 2 millions de personnes
l'Iran fait figure de pays consommateurs
avec des dans des proportions très
élevées euh et le la réponse du système
iranien à cette problématique là est une
réponse extrêmement répressive avec des
moyens que nous réprouvons puisque les
moyens de s'inscrivent pas dans le cadre
des outils de réponse pénale que nous
que nous approuvons euh puisque la
consommation de drogue et la
participation à des trafics est puni de
la peine de mort et les condamnations et
les exécutions pour relatif au
stupéfiant pour l'année 2023 ont
représenté 440 exécutions en 2023 sur
750 donc c'est extrêmement significatif
étant entendu que parallèlement à cette
réponse pénale extrêmement sévère en
Iran vous avez une participation connue
de l'Iran à la production de drogue de
synthèse métamphétamine au fin
d'exportation
voilà avec tous les réseaux connus de
l'Iran dans la région et les groupes
associés à l'Iran dans dans cette région
en Irak également la consommation de de
drogue est sévèrement punie en Irak il y
a une une un renforcement de la lutte
contre la la
la les trafics de stupéciant et la
consommation et il y a un fait qui me
paraît très intéressant pour l'Irak
c'est que depuis
2017 et encore plus aujourd'hui les
autorités irakiennes considère la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée et plus
particulièrement la lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants comme menace de
sécurité nationale numéro 1 devant le
terrorisme donc ça correspond à la
transition de la période daesh où le
terrorisme était la menace numéro 1 à la
période d'aujourd'hui où cette menace
est relaguée au second plan des des
priorités raison pour laquelle la les
les nos coopérations avec l'Irak dans ce
domaine de de la lutte contre les
stupéfiants se développent je pourrais
poursuivre un petit peu mais je pense
qu'il vaut mieux que je laisse mes mes
camarades parler de leur
zone bonjour donc moi je suis
Jean-Christophe leur ma zone
géographique démarche à partir de la
Colombie et se termine à auchosua sauf
le Surinam et le guinana qui est couvert
par mon collègue Frédéric de Touchet qui
interviendra et qui est rattaché à la
zone Caraïbe alors ce que je peux dire
pour ma zone c'est qu'en fait à part le
Venezuela sur lequel je reviendrai
ensuite nous avons affaire à des pays
affinitaires avec lesquels notre
coopération est excellente dans beaucoup
de domaines y compris dans celui-là
grâce notamment à notre réseau des
attachés des sécurités intérieures voire
même des magistrats de laison nous avons
également à dose homéopathique mais
quand même c'est très important dans ces
pays euh des des soutiens comme par
exemple un expert technique
international à la devvida au Pérou et
c'est donc avec ce réseau que nous
pouvons améliorer notre notre
coopération alors je voudrais parler euh
faire un un petit point d'actualité sur
trois pays parceque 10 pays je pense que
ce serait beaucoup trop long et il me
faudrait bien plus que 5 minutes euh
tout d'abord la Colombie euh puisque euh
la Colombie est un pays qui a euh connu
des évolutions politiques très
importantes et euh Gustavo Petro euh le
le nouveau chef d'État colombien prenant
acte et critiquant l'échec de la guerre
contre la drogue a mené avec l'aide des
États-Unis euh qui qui a été mené avec
l'aide des États-Unis ces dernières
années qui était beaucoup centré sur
l'éradication forcée de la coca a décidé
un changement d'approche un changement
d'approche qui est qui est basé sur euh
s'attaquer au flux financiers des
trafiquants et d'autre part inciter euh
les les propriétaires les paysans à à se
reconvertir et donc cette cette lutte
contre la drogue s'inscrit
dans le cadre de l'accord de paix de
2016 ça fait c'est une partie intégrante
en fait de l'accord de paix mais c'est
une tâche extrêmement compliquée à
accomplir parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
groupes différents dont certains sont
devenus étaient devenus s'étit
transformés de groupes politiques en
groupe en groupe criminel et dont la
source de revenu principale est le
narcotrafic l'autre pays qui qui a fait
l'objet d'une actualité récente dont
vous avez sans doute entendu parler
c'est l'équateur euh notamment avec une
prise d'ottage spectaculaire en direct à
la télévision le le 9 janvier qui en
fait a révélé une situation qui s'est
dégradée déjà depuis depuis plusieurs
années qui était en partie liée
d'ailleurs à une relative amélioration
de la de la situation en Colombie la
Colombie est la première productrice de
cocaïne mais en fait 70 % de la cocaïne
qui vient en Europe provient de
l'équateur donc l'équateur est
producteur mais surtout un pays de de
transit alors la situation est très est
très sérieuse le jeune gouvernement de
du président nouvellement élu Noboa
essae de prendre la mesure de la tâche
c'est évidemment extrêmement compliqué
car vous l'avez compris et d'ailleurs
l'assassinat du procureur qui menait
l'enquête ces derniers jours l' l'a
prouvé qu'en réalité l'ensemble du
système est gangrainé par par les
trafiquants de drogue les prisons
elles-même il y avait eu des révoltes
dans les prisons avaient fait des
centaines de morts les prisons comme au
Venezuela d'ailleurs j'en parlerai sont
aux mains en fait des des
narcotrafiquants ce sont des zones de
non droit euh donc la tâche est immense
pour ce pour ce jeune gouvernement qui
d'ailleurs va devoir repasser par les
urnes dans un an et demi parce qu'en
fait le président était élu suite à la
destitution et la dissolution de
l'Assemblée c'est le système qu'on
appelle de mort croisé en Équateur qui
fait que les électeurs ont été à nouveau
appelés aux urnes pour la fin du mandat
de son prédécesseur Guillermo lasso
alors sur ce pays naturellement nous
nous sommes y sommes très attentif euh
nous sommes en train de nous coordonner
avec les directions compétentes donc la
DCSD chez nous la dire diretion de la
coopération de la sécurité de défense le
ministère de l'Intérieur et des
outresmères le ministère des armées pour
voir quelle est la meilleure euh euh le
meilleur soutien que nous pouvons
apporter également en coordination avec
les autres États qui vont apporter leur
soutien le Chili l'a annoncé les
États-Unis naturellement donc il faut
que nous insérons dans un processus
collectif pour que notre appui soit à la
fois efficace non redodant ou appui
peut-être des actions menées par par
d'autres et j'en terminerai par le
Venezuela alors le Venezuela c'est un
cas particulier dans la région comme
vous le savez nous n'avons pas reconnu
les élections présidentielles et
législatives qui ont lieu au Venezuela
nous avons néanmoins contenu de
l'évolution plutôt positive de la
situation politique notamment avec
l'accord de la Barbade qui a été signé
euh le 17 octobre nous avons décidé de
nommer un ambassadeur euh l'ambassade du
Venezuela est également ici à Paris avec
un nouvel ambassadeur qui a été nommé
donc nous essayons de euh de renouer des
relations politiques avec ce pays tout
dépendra évidemment de la situation
l'évolution de la situation des droits
de l'homme et la tenue des élections
présidentielles en en 2024 que nous nous
souhaitons libre et et transparente mais
avec le Venezuela en fait sur ce le plan
du du trafic de drogue nous avons une
une une coopération qui s'est avéré
efficace notamment nous avons beaucoup
de sollicitations pour des demandes
d'arraisonnement en vertu de l'article
17 de la de la convention de de la
Convention de Vienne sur le trafic
illicite de stupéf je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres sur 29 sollicitations
qui ont été faites à l'ensemble du
ministère des Affaires étrangères nous
en avions cinq pour le Venezuela et 4
pour le Brésil sur le Venezuela pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée c'est un peu
de cannabis seulement 320 kg mais plus
de 5,35 tonnes de de cocaïne sur un
total pour l'Amérique du Sud de 7,8 838
tonnes donc le vénzuela présente une
part importante des saisis de cocaïne et
euh au début nous avions quelques
craintes euh parce que le Venezuela
demande à à à à à à à à retrouver la
propriété de cette euh de cette de cette
cocaïne parce que ce sont des des des
navires qui battent pavillon
vénézuéliens et nous avions quelques
craintes car le nous pensons que le
gouvernement nous avons de bonne raison
de penser qu'à l'intérieur du
gouvernement euh il y a beaucoup de
corruption mais finalement les choses se
passent plutôt bien et euh nous
remettons la les saisies au Venezuela
qui est détruite en présence de notre
attaché de sécurité intérieure ce qui
nous donne donc la garantie que cette
drogue n'est pas n'est pas Dét journée
j'en ai terminé
merci merci beaucoup Fréd de Touchet
chef de la mission Mexique Amérique
centrale et Caribes monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs donc très j'essaie d'être
synthétique également de me tenir au à
au temps imparti donc la zone que couvre
la mission de que je
dirige en fait est assez complète et
hétérogène donc al c'est à peu près 225
millions d'habitants don le près de la
moitié euh devient couverte par le
Mexique le Mexique les États-Unis du
Mexique donc le à 44 57 millions 54
millions d'habitants dans les 7 pays de
la de l'Amérique centrale et à peu près
44 dans 80 millions dans les Caraïbes la
particularité donc le Surinam et le
Guyana à EU2 font 1 mil00on et dei euh
donc également la mission d'Amérique
centrale et Caribes traite de de toutes
les organisations sous-régionales la
plus importante pour la sécurité dans la
CARICOM mais également l'AEC
l'association des états de la carïbe et
l'OCO l'Organisation des États de la
carïbe orientale donc cette direction
aussi est par définition
l'interlocutrice également de du
ministère de l'Intérieur et des outres m
en ce qui concerne en tout cas lescalité
française d'Amérique des Antilles mais
également la Guyane que nous partageons
avec nos collègues d'Amérique du Sud
donc ça pour un peu le contexte général
de cette zone euh la plupart des pays
d'Amérique centrale en tout cas
duappelle le triangle Nord euh euh
Nicaragua Salvador Honduras ont connu
des conflits des guerres civiles
prolongées qui ont terminé dans les
années 90 donc c'est un facteur
d'explication cette zone est confrontée
à plusieurs problèmes important qui sont
sources de trafic illicite donc une
immigration massive donc qui a pour pour
quelques chiffres du Sud vers les
États-Unis également de Cuba et de Haïti
en gros en en 2002 le 2022 on a eu un
doublement on est passé à 250000 contre
130 et probablement cette année 2023 on
serait plutôt aux alentours de 500000
migrant qui traverse ce qu'on appelle le
bouchon du Darien c'est la frontière
entre la Colombie et le Panama c'estd
pour un pays de 5 millions d'habitants
ça
représente un défi absolument
colossal donc évidemment ces trafics
s'accompagnent de trafic d'êtres humains
trafic d'armes évidment de trafic de
narcotrafic on estime généralement que
l'Amérique centrale et les Caribes sont
des zon de transit ou de rebond cette
typologie est en train de changer il
semble qu'il y ait des des plantations
de de coca au Honduras et au Guatemala à
vérifier
euh
donc évidemment c'est c'est ces
producteurs sont sont éement touchés par
le la diversification massive des des
des sources de euh de réexportation en
particulier vers l'Europe à travers les
Caraïbes donc ça concerne directement de
collectivité de la région la Martinique
la Guadeloupe et la Guyane donc pour les
États en question cela s'accompagne de
de de quel quel quel type de risque donc
des groupes criminels organisés
structurés extrêmement puissants et qui
sont assez résilients donc à titre
d'exemple la la guerre contre les les
gangs au Mexique de 2006 à 2012 a fait
500 en gros 500000 morts 50000 morts
pardon et on donc on ne sait pas ce
qu'il en est stir les cartels sont
toujours là ils ont toujours quasiment
je pas deuxè producteur mondial
d'héroïne je crois en tout cas
d'exportateurs dans les pays d'Amérique
centrale ce qui est intéressant noter on
est la tentation de la de l'état
d'urgence et de la réponse musclée donc
on a un exemple qui est celui du
Salvador avec un président extrêmement
populaire donc qui devrait être réélu le
4 février donc sur un pays de un peu
moins de 5 millions d'habitants un peu
plus de 5 millions d'habitants 70000
arrestations don toutes les bandes euh
sont sont enfin supposit-elles sont
incarcéré en tout cas le résultat est
tel que cela a permis de rétablir la
sécurité de faire baisser le taux de
criminalité le Honduras a suivi cet
exemple donc état d'urgence dans
certaines zones voir d'autres États
caribens la Jamaïque en décembre 2022 ce
qui est intéressant aussi de noter c'est
que des états relativement préservés
jusqu'à maintenant qui sont le le Panama
et le Costa Rica sont de plus en plus
touchés au point que lorsqu'il est venu
en France au mois d'avril le président
Chab trouver président de la République
et donc a indiqué qu'il
souhaitait contrôler l'ensemble des
ports et des aéroports susceptible de
transporter de la drogue en installant
des des des portails qui permettent de
rapidement de de visualiser si de la
drogue se trouve dans les conttainers
les containers étant de 80 % du trafic
maritime du pays également si j'ai bien
compris la la la drogue la cocaïne
transportée par voie maritime par
container représente 4080 % du tout qui
est l'enjeu pour la la
France donc on a déjà premièrement on
assiste à une très forte augmentation
des prises en mer par la Marine
nationale basé aux Antilles les forces
armées des Antilles qui ont saisi serit
en une seule opération sur un bateau
pavillon venezuélien 3 ton et demi de
cocaïne en décembre 2023 et en tout le
le
chiffre c'est je crois si on est de
l'ORD de 11 tonnes de cocaïne en 2023
rien que pour les les forces armées de
guilla de de pardon de la de la
Martinique
donc face à cette évolution la réponse
est de plusieurs ordres sur le plan
diplomatique nous avons des accords de
coopération contre le narcotrafic avec
le Mexique en vigueur depuis 2008 et
naturellement nous sommes en train de
négocier avec un certain nombre de pays
des accords de de coopération judiciaire
et pénale on y travaille beaucoup sur le
plan opérationnel je pense que le
dispositif repose essentiellement dans
sur le réseau des Asies mais beaucoup
aussi sur le le bureau de l'ofaste en
particulier en Martinique qui a une
antenne maintenant à sain-lucie dans sa
capitale castri donc c c'est un
l'important la nouvelle aussi qui montre
à quel point notre dispositif monte en
puissance c'est la nomination annoncée
prochaine
d'un magistrat de liaison qui sera basé
à à castri avec une compétence
élargie audelà même de la Caraïbe ça
vient d'être annoncé juste avant la fin
de
l'année nous avons aussi à titre
bilatéral un outil qui vaut la peine
d'être nommé qui s'appelle alcorka qui
existe depuis 8 ans et qui alcorka ça
veut dire appui à la lutte contre le
crime organisé en région caraïbe donc
qui est basé au sein de l'Académie
nationale de contrôle des drogues à
saint-domain et géré par l'Asie un Asie
dédié le visement annuel est de l'ordre
de 180000 € donc en tout en en 8 ans on
a eu 1258 stagiaires formés et la
décision a été prise d'élargir ce
programme au Panama et au Costa Rica à
la demande de ces deux états donc ça
posera un problème de probblement de
financement de capacité en tout cas
c'est une priorité qui a été qui a été
clairement identifiée par la DCSD la
Direction de la Coopération de sécurité
de défense du ministère des Affaires
étrangères et donc autre outil sur place
utile absolument indispensable c'est le
cfast le centre interministériel de
formation antistub de port-defance
donc je je n'élaborerai pas sur le le
rôle de El pacto puisque vous avez
entendu je crois un certain nombre de de
praticiens beaucoup plus que ce soit
européens ou ou lofast et et copolade
qui est une un programme européen doté
de 15 millions de d'euros sur 4 ans à
partir de
2021 et qui qui a également le vocation
à aider les les à développer la
stratégie entre l'UE et le et les pays
d'Amérique latine et des Caraïbes pour
améliorer leur leur politique de lutte
contre les stupéfiants voilà dernier
élément absolument fondamental également
le rôle de de la CARICOM et de son son
agence dédiée qui s'appelle
l'lementation agency for cri security
qui a été créé en
2006 donc évidemment dans A autre outil
autre outil du maillage le CCAD le
centre caribéen pour la lutte de la et
la prévention en matière de
drogue donc c'est C CC ça veut dire
Commission interaméricaine de lutte
contre l'abus des drogues donc voilà
c'est un peu l'essentiel du dispositif
là ce qu'il faut IR c'est que l'État met
les moyens contenu je pense simplement
de l'état de la menace pour mémoire sur
les prises à envers en cette année c'est
116 millions de tonnes de cocaïne donc
lere est touché beaucoup d'autres villes
en France pas seulement des poorts
d'ailleurs ça pose un problème de réseau
d'efficacité de de coopération
opérationnelle et pour finir aussi je
dire à quel point c'est important pour
nos nos collectivités de d'Amérique
des d'Amérique le président de la
collectivité Thel de Martinique a
participé à un séminaire dédié au mois
d'avril porort d'Espagne en Trinité et
Tobago séminaire dédié à la lutte contre
le contre le trafic de drogue et il faut
savoir également que la Martinique comme
les autres collectivités ambitionne de
d'adhérer comme membre non associé à la
CARICOM voilà j'en ai fini je suis à
votre disposition pour préciser certains
aspects mais voà je dire à quel point
ces ces éléments sont importants pour
nos postes pour nous-mêmes et demandent
également un
euh sachant certains nous avons des des
ambassades qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
PPD des postes à présence diplomatique
donc c'est un défi pour eux de pouvoir
euh euh avoir les capacités à suivre et
à relayer éventuellement des des
demandes notamment en ce qui concerne le
rôle des forces armée euh des Antilles
et de la Marine nationale donc là-dessus
euh sachant que évidemment quand il
s'agit d'intercepter des bateaux rapides
il faut des accords avec les pays
limitrophes donc c'est un peu tout
l'enjeu de euh du travail diplomatique
français dans les Caraïbes je vous
remercie merci beaucoup jeanclaud Brunet
pour
terminer Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
les sénateurs euh alors je souhaiterais
intervenir à double titre à vraid
puisque j'ai je suis actuellement
ambassadeur en charge de la coopération
régionale dans l'océan inden donc je
vais vous parler dans un deuxième temps
aussi de de particulièrement de cette
région et qui a des problématiques
similaires puisque nous travaillons avec
avec l'outremire et avec les
collectivités mais je j'ai
exercé précédemment les fonctions de
d'ambassadeur en charge de la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée ensemble
donc avec la la direction des affaires
stratégique et donc Madame Amélie de la
roche et je voulais compléter par mon
expérience passée
et faire une transition effectivement
vers les points spécifiques à l'océan
Indien pour souligner mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à quel point
effectivement avec le plan national de
2019 antistupéfiant comme ma collègue
l'a l'a
souligné nous avons un travail en
coordination entre tous les ministères
et les agences concernées et vraiment en
appui à Stéphanie charbonnier la chef de
l'offast et ses services et qui ont ce
comme vous le savez ce caractère intégré
police justice douane et donc k doré
Affaires étrangères en appui même si
nous n'avons pas de personnel à
l'intérieur de l'auface nous sommes
partenairire et chef de groupe de
travail en particulier effectivement sur
cette dimension du dialogue politique or
ce que je voulais souligner c'est que ça
nous a permis collectivement et à
l'intérieur effectivement aussi du du qu
d'orsé et en liaison avec nos ambassades
région par région de travailler en sur
deux priorités l'une l'opérationnel en
soutien à l'ofaste faire mobiliser les
ambassades et donc et notre action
diplomatique en soutien par exemple pour
obtenir le cadre juridique nécessaire à
l'action de l'offaste dans selon la
typologie des actions qu'ils peuvent
mener le maximum étant par exemple les
équipes conjointes d'enquête sur le
modèle de la l'équipe franco-espagnole
on va dire et ou franco-colombienne mais
après il y a toute une gradation aussi
de qui avait été définie une stratégie
par l'opaste et nous nous avons informer
les postes à l'époque et c'est donc un
processus constant des des besoins
particuliers de l'ofast puisque pour une
efficacité opérationnelle maximale
effectivement il est les contacts entre
les les professionnels les acteurs de du
renseignement et de la répression
doivent absolument euh améliorer leur
leur modalité de de coopération ça c'est
le premier point mais ça nous a servi
aussi et ça a été un saut qualitatif
extrêmement important par rapport au
passé à région par région pour les les
régions
prioritaires les pays de première
priorité mais nous avons ajouter parce
que la première priorité c'était les les
premières priorités pour l'opaste pour
les raisons que j'indique mais on a pu
définir une une priorité de seconde
priorité si vous voulez euh c'est-à-dire
ceux qui pourraient euh devenir en un
point d'inquiétude plus important euh à
l'avenir euh ou euh donc au titre de la
prévention ou qui ou qui représente tout
simplement en effet pour nos intérêts
une seconde priorité et sur laquelle il
il est important autant que pour la
liste définie par l'ofaste de mieux se
coordonner euh dans les programmes de
renforcement de capacité et donc mes mes
collègues des autres zones ont évoqué un
certain nombre de programmes
effectivement dans les Caraïbes alcorca
ou el pacto alors et donc cette
structuration par le plan national
d'action nous aide à assurer à effectuer
un suivi interministériel euh de de
l'état des lieux de nos programmes pour
et et pour améliorer euh les synergies
entre ces programmes évaluer leur
efficacité savoir s'il y a pas de
nécessité d'en changer éventuellement et
surtout de mobiliser l'Union européenne
et donc la coordination avec l'Union
européenne et dans dans les différentes
zones notamment en Amérique latine donc
on a notamment impliqué les équipes
Europe dans le cadre en Pact ou dans le
cadre de de cadre ad hoc UE pays pays
partenaire et ça c'est effectivement
aussi un point important dans la la
mobilisation puisque donc ce plan
national français s'inscrit dans une
mobilisation plus large européenne et
Don dont les les dimensions extérieures
sont également beaucoup mieux
coordonnées à présent avec les nôtres
euh je voulais indiquer aussi que donc
ça permet aussi un suivi des résultats
il est important aussi et c'est et c'est
également la possibilité de mettre
l'accent sur des approches régionales
parce qu'on le voit dans beaucoup de
domaines de lutte contre la criminalité
organisé ça peut être extrêmement utile
vis-à-vis de pays on qu'on aide
renforcer les capacités mais qui ont
peut-être du mal à prioriser ces sujets
en interne qui peuvent être aussi sujets
à à des fragilité
euh si les intérêts des narcos sont trop
trop forts c'est pas forcément des
mesures qui vont prendre aisément
politiquement euh donc il y a un les
processus régionaux peuvent amener une
certaine émulation entre les pays euh
sachant que par exemple si l'Union
européenne apporte de l'aide financière
à un groupe de pays et un dialogue et a
un réseutage qui permet aux
professionnels de la répression et de
des enquêtes de se rencontrer mais s'il
y a ce processus il peut y avoir aussi
un un suivi des résultats et ça peut
être important de créer un une logique
régionale avec effectivement comme ce
que j'appellerai une sorte d'émulation
euh sachant que le pays qui sera le
dernier apparaîtra bien tel et comme le
pays qui est le plus rétif à des à des
actions donc c'est ça pour la question
du du suivi et des indicateurs qui sont
en matière de de internationale de lutte
contre la criminalité organisée on l'a
vu aussi sur la lutte contre les trafics
d'armes dans certaines régions c'est
recommandé par les conférences des
nations- Unies d'agir de la sorte de
manière régionale d'ailleurs les pays
entre pays voisins ont des intérêts
objectivement communs aussi à à discuter
donc voilà sur le le
plan thématique maintenant j'en viens à
l'océan Indien pour indiquer que c'est
une région qui apparaît peut-être pas
encore tout à fait dans
le les toutes premières priorités
notamment de l'ofaste en terme de risque
et d'urgence à agir pour nous mais je je
je dois dire que c'est de plus en plus
une région effectivement qui que nous
sur laquelle nous nous accordons sur la
nécessité d'agir en
prévention sur ce sujet et on voit des
des saisies effectivement aussi très
importantes euh et en prévention je
dirais parce qu'on a une situation qui
voit quand même les céchelles euh
Maurice et Madagascar être ces dernières
années très fortement touché par les
trafics de drogue en
provenance d'Asie centrale et de donc
d'Afghanistan donc essentiellement
héroïne mais aussi d'autres des des
drogues de synthèse euh nous sommes avec
la Réunion et Mayot plus touché par les
drogues type cocaïne et cannabis mais
nous sommes n sommes donc il y a deux
séries de mais ça aussi de manière
croissante donc il y a une une équipe de
l'fast à la Réunion qui gère qui
s'occupe à la fois de la Réunion et de
Mayotte et qui a été donc créé et
renforcé nous avons la gendarmerie
d'outre m mais nous sommes donc
effectivement dans une zone qui est
particulièrement inquiète de voir enfin
c ces phénomènes et se développer donc
pour l'instant c'est deux voies
parallèles le point commun c'est que ce
sont des
trafics accepter les la cocaïne vers la
Réunion qui est plutôt par voie
aérienne le reste c'est effectivement
par la voie maritime
et ce qui explique que nous mettons
l'accent à la fois sur l'action de la
Marine nationale bien sûr mais là aussi
déjà il y a l'Europe avec Atalanta
c'est-à-dire que nous avons cont tenu
des routes maritimes en question et de
de la l'enjeu de la sécurité maritime en
tant que telle et toute la mobilisation
qui a été faite aussi sur la lutte
antipiraterie ou anti
trafic donc on a une une une nous
pouvons conjuguer effectivement les
actions nationales et européennes et
même et donc nous avons du bilatéral et
du régional alors et d'autant plus que
l'Union européenne comme je mentionné
avec les équipes Europe ou d'autres
programmes aime bien sur ces sujets
s'appuyer sur des organisations
régionales et c'est ce qui a été fait
dans l'océan Indien puisque sur la
sécurité maritime donc on a la
Commission de l'Océan Indien don nous
sommes membres la France et au titre de
la Réunion mais aussi sur les les sujets
de sécurité maritime ça inclu le
périmètre à la fois de la Réunion et de
Mayotte et la et l'action
aussi malgré le différent territorial
que nous avons avec les Comores sur la
souveraineté française sur mayott donc
sur les sujets de sécurité maritime les
deux collectivité sont entièrement
couvertes par un programme qui est géré
par la Commission de l'Océan Indien à la
demande de l'Union européne EUR avec des
financements de l'Union européenne et en
particulier sur pour deux plans de de de
de composante principalement
l'architecture régionale de sécurité
maritime donc ce sont deux centres donc
l'un de fusion
d'information maritime qui est à
Madagascar et l'autre de de coordination
opérationnelle au séchel nous avons des
officiers de liaison dans ces deux
centres nous avons aussi des officiers
de liaison au centre plus au nord dans
dans l'océan Indien qui a euh et nous
allons renforcer notre appui à la
gouvernance de ces centres prochainement
pour les faciliter leur utilisation
opérationnelle dans la lutte contre la
les trafics de drogue
notamment et et donc ça c'est c'est un
point un point important le deuxème
deuxème élément c'est que l'Union
européenne va donc
rajouter encore 15 millions d'euros au
25 millions d'euros qu'elle accordé à ce
programme de sécurité maritime régionale
euh pour le les les prochains
euh prochains c c années euh et en
particulier pour renforcer les
financements aux actions de de
renforcement de capacité euh mené par
l'ONUDC ma collègue a parlé aussi de
notre notre action avec l'ONUDC donc là
ça va être le cas qui va aider
effectivement les pays de la région à
renforcer leurs capacités et nous aider
à améliorer les relations bilatérales
euh pour faciliter les contacts entre
les services opérationnels euh je
voudrais aussi ajouter que nous avons un
un les pays de la nous coopérons bien
avec les pays de la région en
particulier aussi avec Maurice comme
vous savez une une convention en de
coopération judiciaire entre la France
et Maurice en
2022 a été signée elle est je crois euh
la le le projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation et est soumis actuellement
à la commission des affaires étrangères
du Sénat euh nous allons euh nous et
donc le pays Maurice est effectivement
le l'île c'est l'île la plus proche de
la Réunion et qui a développe des des
liens étroits de coopération dans tous
les domaines de sécurité y compris la la
gestion des migrations irrégulières euh
et la lutte contre les trafic de
droguees a
été érigé en en priorité régionale par
le gouvernement de Maurice qui qui a
organisé l'année dernière pour la
première fois une conférence régionale
qui a adopté une déclaration et il va y
avoir une nouvelle conférence en 2024 ça
va permettre aussi de d'opérationnaliser
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui ont
été discutés notamment euh la ce qui
avait été évoqué lors d'une réunion de
de l'UA et avec les pays africains aussi
mais d'un d'un forum des des fonctions
garde-côte c'est qu'il va y avoir des
réunions aussi dans l'océan Indien et en
liaison avec nos partenaires africains
euh entre tous les services garde-côte
et les fonctions garde-côte donc qui
permettra aussi de discuter des des
modalités de pour améliorer notre
efficacité opérationnelle je voudrais
dire aussi qu'en franco-français comme
nous disons nous aurons une conférence
de coopération régionale avec les
collectivités d'outrem avec le ministère
chargé des outr Mr Le qu d'orset les
administrations centrales les préfets
les ambassadeurs euh au mois d'avril à
Mayotte et nous associerons aussi les
les procureurs avec la police la
gendarmerie euh pour voir effectivement
faire un point de situation nous avons
dans l'océan Indien des distances
maritimes beaucoup plus grandes que dans
les Antilles et donc nous avons un vrai
sujet de judiciarisation c'est quand la
Marine nationale saisit des cargaisons
et des trafiquan euh elle n'est pas en
mesure pour le moment de débarquer ces
trafiquants dans des pays et des îles
euh de la région avec la garantie qu'il
y aura une judiciarisation le premier
pays qui a accepté de signer un tel
texte avec l'Union européenne c'est les
Séchelles donc on va voir si les autres
vont le faire mais ça c'est notamment un
sujet un problème que nous rencontrons
et que et que nous nous discuterons tout
dernier point c'est que la réunion va
être en mesure aussi de développer ses
capacités d'accueil de séminaaires de
rencontres de de professionnels parce
que nous travaillons à la au
développement de de d'écoles ou de
centes de formation à vocation régionale
un peu aussi sur le modèle de ce qui se
développe dans le Pacifique et qu'on
appelle l'Académie de sécurité le
président de la République on a parlé et
nous avons avec le cross réunion la
gendarmerie d'autr MRE et aussi sur les
risques naturels avec la la plateforme
de la Croix-Rouge les capacités aussi
développer une une académie de sécurité
à la Réunion
merci merci beaucoup notre rapporteur va
prendre le merci de cette présentation
particulièrement dense et on le sait la
lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants
contre les réseaux de narcotiques
euh sont initiés par des échanges
d'information c'est l'information qui
fait la lutte contre le le
narcotrafic est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler la circulation de ces
informations dans le cadre des
responsabilités qui sont les vôtres les
liens que vous avez avec nos
ambassadeurs avec les magistrats de
liaison les liens aussi que vous avez
avec nos partenaires européens vous l'z
très bien expliqué on est sur dans
certains secteurs on est très coordonné
avec les Européens et puis peut-être
aussi les liens que nous avons avec
l'ONU et ces organisations
internationales est-ce que vous jugez
suffisant la circulation de de
l'information est-ce que vous y accédez
facilement on est sur des sujets qui
exigent une confidentialité notamment
quand les affaires sont
piloté
par la justice dans ces différents pays
est-ce que vous pouvezous nous éclairer
un petit peu
là-dessus merci pour pour cette question
eu par information si on l'entend dans
une acception large ça comprend le
renseignement aussi et c'est évidemment
c'est évidemment clé nous on a besoin en
tant que diplomate de l'accès au
renseignement pour savoir
euh et puis je parle donc venant de la
Direction des Affaires stratégiques ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la façon dont
nous sommes impactés
euh de façon globale mais mais au plan
sécuritaire aussi par la menace incarnée
par le le trafic de stupéfiant et donc
comme vous le soullignez la l'accès à
l'information est clé eu nous disposons
de l'information par le biais de nos
services renseignement 1er et 2è cercle
euh
et nous avons un un dialogue
étroit sans entrer plus dans les détails
ici nous avons également accès à
l'information qui
est qui est accumulé par par les
enceintes européennes et internationales
donc je mentionnais tout à l'heure
l'Observatoire
européen qui qui est en train de de se
transformer en véritable
agence nous avons également l'ONUC qui
qui émet des qui publie des rapports
annuels sur l'état de la de l'état des
drogues dans le monde et avec parfois
des des publications sur certaines
régions ou certains types de drogue plus
particulièrement donc je pense que nous
avons un accès à l'information qui est
qui est globalement assez bon
[Musique]
euh mais il est vrai que voilà il y a on
touche évidemment à des des à des
domaines très sensibles et que la le
degré d'information dont nous pouvons
disposer dépend aussi de l'état de la
coopération bilatérale que nous pouvons
avoir avec tel ou tel pays j'espère que
ça répond à votre question
oui de de mon côté peut-être de deux
compléments par rapport à ce que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure la d'abord pour
dans dans mes fonctions actuelles j'ai
tout tout à fait accès au renseignements
effectivement euh de du côté
de la DGSE mais aussi de dans les
relations classiques qui est dor des GSE
mais surtout sur la le sujet des drogues
avec le l'équipe de l'ofast à la Réunion
bien sûr
euh mais ce que je voulais parler de
l'Europe aussi parce que j'ai évoqué cet
enjeu de partage d'information donc dans
ce le centre de fusion d'information à
Madagascar ou celui d' l et le centre
opérationnel ça ça va être un enjeu pour
la la suite maintenant pour la la pleine
opérationnalisation de cette
architecture de sécurité maritime mais
il y a un autre instrument dont j'ai pas
parlé c'est qui est également géré par
la Commission de l'Océan Indien avec des
financements européens et euh très
opérationnel qui est le le programme sur
la sécurité portuaire et le point commun
entre les deux c'est qu'en fait il y a
un programme européen qui s'appelle
criario euh qui euh dispose en fait qui
justement c'est par ce programme que ce
se finance un certain nombre d'actions
de l'ONUDC régionale mais pas seulement
à vrai dire puisqu'il y a aussi et c'est
très très important c'est des une
plateforme d'échange d'information qui
s'appelle
yoris qui que nous promouvons dans le
contexte de la stratégie indopacifique
donc à la fois en zone Océan Indien et
Pacifique parce que alors elle est elle
est elle est a une une utilisation dans
le domaine de
la sécurité maritime au sens de l'aide
au navires en difficulté et de la
prévention des catastrophes euh mais
aussi et en particulier pour la sécurité
portuaire dans la lutte contre les
trafic c'est de l'échange d'information
par cette plateforme et c'est une il
existe d'autres plateformes proposées
par d'autres pays dans le monde mais la
la l'Europe propose une plateforme
extrêmement flexible où il est le les
pays décident de partager l'information
qu'il souhaite partager euh avec qui il
le souhaite et il y a des des
protections euh mais nous faisons donc
une promotion de cet instrument Yuris
cette plateforme et elle peut et et donc
par sur le programme de sécurité
portuaire il est prévu que le tour de
table des services répressifs et
disposant d'informations sur la le
trafic de de drogue ou d'autres trafic
d'ailleurs puissent utiliser cette
plateforme et donc n c'est un enjeu
effectivement aussi opérationnel et
d'efficacité
une une une autre question
sur un certain nombre de pays qui nous
sont hostiles et je veux parler de
l'Iran je veux parler de l'IRAC est-ce
que selon vous quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure que l'Iran était un pays
exportateur je sais pas je crois que
c'est vous qui le disiez est-ce que
selon vous euh il y a une stratégie de
l'Iran de déstabilisation d'Occident
avec
les
narcotiques et pas seulement de
l'Iran alors spécifiquement sur l'Iran
ma réponse est oui il y a une stratégie
qui est
euh assumer des autorités iraniennes de
de laisser cette production de
métamphétamine se avoir lieu sur leur
territoire et puis ensuite partir à
l'étranger euh ça n'est pas la seule
modalité de déstabilisation euh de de
l'environnement régional de l'Iran et de
l'environnement même qui va au-delà du
régional puisque l'Iran a d'autres
méthodes mais c'est une méthode qui fait
partie de cette stratégie de
déstabilisation oui
euh en terme de coopération bilatérale
l'Irak est plutôt un pays avec lequel
nous réussissons à construire des choses
de façon très constructive et ça nous
aide beaucoup parce que comme vous le
savez très bien l'Irak c'est un pays
c'est le pays charnière du Moyen-Orient
qui partage une très longue frontière
avec la Syrie une très longue frontière
avec l'Iran une très longue frontière
avec l'Arabie Saoudite une frontière
avec la Turquie euh un accès aux EAU du
golf aux EAU du golf et donc évidemment
il est important que nous puissions
déployer des actions de coopération avec
l'Irak dans ce domaine-là ce que nous
nous attachons à faire de façon très
solide depuis 2018-209 c'est-à-dire
depuis que l'effacement progressif de la
priorité accordé à la lutte contre daesh
laisse la place à d'autres types de
coopération avec l'IRAC en revanche
toute forme de coopération avec l'Iran
est absolument impossible sur ce sujet
et sur la
Syrie alors sur la Syrie je suis pas sûr
d'être formellement en droit de vous
répondre puisque puisque ça fait pas
partie de ma zone donc je vous le je
vous le dis mais sur la Syrie comme vous
le savez nous n'avons plus de
représentants à Damas depuis maintenant
10 ans euh mais la façon le levier
diplomatique que nous avons et que nous
que nous continuons de nous efforcer à
utiliser c'est dans le cadre de la
normalisation de retour du retour de la
Syrie dans son environnement arabe et de
sa réintégration dans la ligue Arab nous
avions encourager nos pays partenaires
de la Ligue arabe et notamment du et nos
pays du Golf d'en faire une condition en
fait de demander de de faire comme de
mettre comme préalable
euh au retour de la Syrie dans ces
instances régionales des efforts en
terme de de sur plusieurs domaines
retour des des réfugiés et cetera mais
aussi sur le voler lutte contre les
narcotrafic ce que nous avons formulé
plusieurs fois et ce que nous continuons
à formuler d'ailleurs puisque les pays
nos pays partenaires et notamment les
pays du golf sont tout à fait
déstabilisés par les trafics et la
consommation de captagon qui viennent de
Syrie donc c'est quelque chose auquel
ils sont sensibles le choix a été fait
par nos partenaires régionaux finalement
d'accorder cette réintégration de la
Syrie à la Ligue Arab euh sans obtenir
de satisfaction sur les leviers
préalables que nous avions fixés et en
espérant que cette réintégration
permette de d'aboutir à des progrès sur
ces différents leviers de ce que nous ne
constatons pas pour le
moment de la roche vouliez non c'est
essentiellement ça je je voulais
simplement effectivement insister sur la
dimension narco-état de de la Syrie
aujourd'hui et le fait que nous nous
encourageons vivement t tous nos
partenaires de la région les les états
de coopération du golf à à évoquer ce
sujet dans le cadre de leur dialogue de
normalisation avec avec la Syrie eu un
dernier mot sur sur l'Iran il y a
effectivement un fort laissé faire mais
vous savez que que l'Iran est soutient
activement ses ses proxis dans dans la
région comme on dit et et à ce titre le
le Hezbollah est également impliqué dans
les trafics de de
captagon je crois qu'on avait des
questions de mariearlette Carlotti
d'ivier cadiic de Marie Lore finera Orte
merci monsieur président mesdames
messieurs merci de vos interventions
c'est intéressant de voir la
mobilisation de la diplomatie française
parce que ça prouve que la France a une
volonté politique de lutter contre le
narcotrafic même si de mon point de vue
aujourd'hui il est temps deafficher une
volonté politique encore plus forte je
voulais vous interroger sur d'abord le
trafic d'héroïnes vous en avez très peu
parlé j'ai très bien compris qu'il se
passait beaucoup de choses sur la
cocaïne sur les drogues de synthèse la
l'héroïne a été terrible il y a quelques
années de ça il y a que vous monsieur
qui en avez parlé en disant qu'il y
avait une production d'héroïnes dans la
zone Mexique enfin vous appelez ça le le
triangle d'or ça veut dire que cette
héroïne se déplace elle est elle est
transformé sur place est-ce qu'il y a
d'après vous des liens avec des
laboratoires qui seraient sur notre
territoire ça c'est la première question
et la deuxième c'est concerne les zones
pays il n'y a pas autour de cette table
une zone qui concerne le Maghreb et en
particulier le Maroc de tout temps le
Maroc a été une un producteur de
cannabis de qualité
disait-il défiant toute concurrence
désormais il semble que ça soit autre
chose que ce soit aussi un lieu de
transit des autres drogues et que c'est
aussi un lieu d'accueil de certains
narcotrafiquants donc bon je sais pas si
c'est un un narco-état je en tout cas ça
peut lui ressembler mais du coup au
regard des des difficultés qu'on a des
relations compliquées entre la France
pour d'autres raisons aujourd'hui et le
Maroc est-ce qu'il y a des coopérations
sur ce point et je sais que la zone
n'est pas représentée mais est-ce que
vous pouvez me répondre merci
toutes les questions et puis on vous
laissera répondre en bloc Olivier
oui premier point le le Venezuela
puisque ça a été
mentionné l'argent du trafic est en
dollars mais pour le blanchir l'or est
souvent utilisé par les les narcos et
les mines illégales d'or et de diamant
pulul au Venezuela et
donc puisque donc ce sont des cri des
organisations internationales
criminelles et donc c'est le moyen de de
blanchir que pouvez-vous nous dire la
situation justement au Venezuela dans
dans ce domaine sur la façon de de
blanchir le trafic et comment est-ce que
la France lutte contre ce trafic d'or
ensuite vous avez pas parlé d'un pays en
Amérique latine qui est le Pérou et
pourtant c'est le deuxème producteur de
cocaïne après le la Colombie euh 70 %
des précurseurs chimiques qui servent à
la fabrication de la cocaïne sont
fabriqué en Chine à Bakou ils sont
livrés par conteneur du 1er octobre au
30 octobre 2023 37 tonnes de précurseurs
chimiques ont été saisis en provenance
de
Chine on voit au Pérou les les les
casinos donc arrivés de tous les côtés
tous les 300 à 500 m quelque part la
plusart tenu par des chinois qui
blanchissent l'argent à partir de 2025
un terminal euh au nord de de liimma un
port chinois va ouvrir ses portes euh la
crainte de beaucoup c'est que tout
rentre et sorte par ce ce terminal
chinois que pouvez-vous nous dire de la
prise en compte que nous faisons de
cette circulation euh via le Pérou
comment est-ce que les organisations
multilatérales s'emparent du contrôle
sur les précurseurs chimiques donc qui
viennent de Chine et quelle pression
diplomatique exerçons-nous sur ce sujet
à l'égard de ce pays j'aurais bien aimé
savoir quel est votre avis sur
l'évolution du nombre d'assassinats pour
100000 habitants en Amérique centrale
puisque c'est un des des sujets et puis
nous le repositionner pour nous donner
une perspective pour par rapport à ce
que l'on vit en France ça permettra de à
tous nos compatriotes de bien se rendre
compte de quelle est la vraie situation
à laquelle sont confronté ces pays du
fait justement de cette criminalité
débridée Marie mar
F merci président oui alors je sais pas
si ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Tallard Fleury ou à Monsieur de toucher
mais on verra bien alors je vais parler
du rapport du Sénat sur le trafic de
stupéfiants en provenance de la Guyane
qui a été rendu en 2020 et qui
préconisait un renforcement de la
coopération internationale et notamment
avec le Surinam et vous le savez la
cocaïne qui transite par la Guyane avant
d'arriver en France hexagonale passe
essentiellement par le syinam donc la ma
question est simple pouvez-vous nous
dire où on est la coopération bilatérale
avec le Surinam et puis j'y ajoute une
une question personnelle
euh dans la qualité de la coopération
avec euh l'ensemble des partenaires que
vous avez cité est-ce que la nature des
politiques qu'il déploie euh qu'elle
soit répressive ou de légalisation je
pense par exemple à l'Uruguay change
quelque chose dans euh dans l'intensité
des résultats qu'on peut avoir ou
euh ou même dans la la sincérité des
démarches oou est-ce que c'est
totalement
indifférent vous laisse vous organiser
oui alors du coup je vais évacuer la la
la la question sur les eiacés en zone
Moyen-Orient euh pour parce que
l'essentiel des questions porte sur la
zone Amérique et Caraïbes
euh c'est c'est toujours un sujet les
opiècés au Moyen-Orient il y a quand
même un fait qui caractérise la
situation aujourd'hui c'est que le le la
source de l'opium était comme vous le
savez l'Afghanistan essentiel qui a eu
un ban qui a été édicté par les talibans
en avril ou mai 2022 et que l'on
constate aujourd'hui une quasi
éradication de la production d'opium en
Afghanistan moi le chiffre que j'ai
c'est - 95 % constaté aujourd'hui par
rapport au pic de 2017 pour cette
raisonlà et donc la source de production
d'opium principale dans la zone qui
m'intéresse
l'Afghanistan est quasi éradiqué alors
ceci dit ça ne veut pas dire que la
question des opiaés en zone Moyen-Orient
est évacué puisque je comprends aussi
sous le contrôle de ceux qui qui suivent
ces questions de façon transversale les
stock sont très importants y compris en
Afghanistan et donc l'Afghanistan
continue à inonder la zone Moyen-Orient
d' Piacé mais la production le le les
flux continuent mais la la les stocks
diminuent
euh et donc effectivement consommation
d'e Piacé encore d'actualité dans la
zone Moyen-Orient mais les flux vont se
tarir on peut l'espérer euh et avec avec
des pays des pays qui aussi étaient
autrefois des pays de transit mais qui
sont de plus en plus des pays de
consommation alors il y avait des pays
de destination finale l'Arabie Saoudite
et les Émirats arabes unis et puis comme
je vous le disais au début ces pays de
transit qui était l'Irak la Jordanie et
cetera sont de plus en plus des pays de
consommation aussi pour les opiacés
c'était pour traiter la question des
opiaés dans la zone
moyen-orientanistanist
produisent non c'est
pas cela dit comme comme ça a bien été
précisé par par mon collègue euh euh
l'Afghanistan reste un fort sujet de de
préoccupation sur les les eiacés euh et
par ailleurs l'Afghanistan devient de de
de de façon de plus en plus importante
un lieu de production pour les
métamphétamines donc avec l'apparition
de laboratoire donc on est on est on
envisage de façon très prudente les
mesures prises par le le régime Taleb on
attend de voir très concrètement encore
comment ça se traduit euh comment s'est
répercuté sur sur les les trafics euh et
et s'agissant de de l'héroïne elle
continue d'affluer et par la route des
Balcans euh aussi par d'autres routes la
route dite du Sud mais ça ça ça reste un
un sujet important un mot peut-être
du du Maghreb du du Maroc même si euh
enfin parce que je je je couvre le sujet
de de façon transversal
euh le Maroc reste
euh le principau pays de principal pays
d'origine pour la la résine de de
cannabis et donc à ce titre la la
coopération avec le Maroc est
prioritaire dans un contexte où vous
l'avez dit les les relations ne sont pas
sont compliquées par tout un ensemble
d'autres facteurs euh mais nous avons
bien comme comme ambition de de pouvoir
poursuivre le dialogue sur sur la
Chine la question des des des
précurseurs et notamment sur les les
drogues de synthèse c'est un sujet c'est
un sujet qui est prioritaire et je et il
est il a certainement précéder pour
beaucoup à au lancement par les
États-Unis de la la coalition
internationale sur les drogues de
synthèse qui qui vise de de leur point
de vue à commencer à exercer une
pression de plus en plus grande sur la
Chine par un ensemble de pays euh avec
des résultats probablement encore très
en de ça de ce que les les États-Unis
aurait souhaité la Chine ne participe
pas à la coalition euh mais si de plus
en plus de pays commencent à évoquer le
le sujet troc de synthèse et des
précurseur avec la Chine
euh voilà enfin en tout cas je il me
semble que c'est une c'est une nécessité
et alors je je ne sais pas précisément
pour le les organisations
internationales mais euh alors le ce qui
est certain c'est que les la Commission
des des stupéfiants que j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure joue un rôle en matière de de
contrôle des des régimes applicables aux
drogues et c'est elle qui actualise
chaque
année les les listes de nouvelles
substances qui qui donc tombent sous
l'gide des des des conventions
internationales de contrôle des drogues
les les trois conventions donc 1961 1971
je peut-être continuer en vous répondant
m la sénatrice aux différentes questions
qui ont été posées concernant la zone
Amérique centrale caribbe Mexique
premièrement je pense qu' une question
sur le sur le Mexique sur les les
statistiques actuellement les chiffres
les plus récents que j'ai c'est le le
producteur le Mexique est le trè
producteur mondial d'héroïne deè
producteur de cannabis et donc c'est
aussi le carrefour de la drogue qui
entre aux États-Unis puisque c'est plus
de 90 % donc maintenant jeux le anil est
devenue maintenant comme ça a été
rappelé 100000 morts aux États-Unis donc
c'est une vraie priorité dans les
relations bilatérales américano
mexicaine enfin et donc le il y a un des
éléments que je voulais signaler aussi
pour répondre à la deuxième question par
la suite c'est que euh dans les pays de
de la de la zone il y a la le sentiment
également que l'approche tout répressive
ne fonctionne pas et donc de plus en
plus d'accent sur la prévention ce
quilique aussi d'ailleurs qu'on aussi un
intérêt pour la coopération
internationale y compris avec la France
et et et l'Union européenne donc pour
revenir au Mexique le un des problèmes
importants euh disons structurel c'est
le le très faible taux d'élucidation des
crimes c'est c'est-à-dire en gros euh il
est de moins de 10 % et encore en étant
assez optimiste donc cette cette à la
fois le le côté la violence endémique
les 10 cartels les plus puissants euh et
donc les les atrocités qui se produisent
régulièrement donc on a ce phénomène
l'autre point concernant le Mexique
c'est là la faiblesse de la des aut de
la police et donc le fait que le
président actuel qui achèvera son mandat
le 2 le 2 juin monsieur Lopez Obrador a
a confié la gestion des ports un certain
nombre d'endroit stratégi à l'armée don
non pas au service de des douanes ou
autres donc avec des résultats je sais
pas que si les résultats sont très
probants en tout cas ça a été un choix
qui a été fait critiqué par certains
dans la mesure où le l'armée est censé
tout faire donc voilà ça c'est la
première chose sur les le taux
d'homicide
t qu'on a donc au Mexique qui c'est
quand même 500000 migrants par an qui
franchissent le rio Bravo grosso
modo donc le le actuellement ce serait
de l'ordre de 27 à pour 100000 habitants
je sais pas si ça évolue régulièrement
sur les donc les records dans la zone
c'est quand même je pense on peut dire
le le Honduras qui était à combien était
le Honduras que je vous dise cela le
Honduras cétait en terme de de mort de
de T domicide par habitant à 40 % 1000
je pense que c'est un c'est un chiffre
qui fait réfléchir c'est lié aussi à
l'informalité également au fait que ce
pays a connu une guerre civile dans
lequel les entre disons le les les
victimes ont été des minorités indigèes
qui représente d'ailleurs plus de la
moitié de la population diverses
populations Maya donc des accusations de
génocide qui nont jamais été luicidé et
personne n'a été jugé en tout cas le
principal responsable est mort avant son
procès euh
donc le le contre exemple étant celui du
du
Salvador qui sous l'effet de la
politique menée par le président naï
boukell qui a procédé à des arrestations
massives et instauré un état d'urgence
qui dure depuis maintenant plus d'un an
et demi donc en gros le taux de le taux
d'homicide a a chuté d'à peu près 56 %
donc il est on retombe à des à des taux
quand même assez assez enfin
comparativement à la zone très très
enfin qui sont beaucoup plus faibles on
est on est à moins de de 20 de 20 de 20%
1000 donc on est en contraste par
rapport aux trois pays du triangle au
deux autres pays du triangle Nord
Guatemala onuras sur une trajectoire qui
qui est disons plus efficass et qui
explique notamment le taux de de
popularité
euh extrême autant qu'on puisse sifier
du du président qui va se représenter
euh donc qui est en gros crédité de plus
80 % des des son sondage qui a déjà la
majorité des 2/ers au Parlement et qui
peut faire à peu près ce qui veut mais
encore une fois c'est la réponse des
populations à une une amélioration de la
sécurité dans les rues et donc la
sécurité de de de tous et de chacun
voilà donc c'est un peu ce que je
voulais vous dire je sais pas si répondu
à toutes les questions sur le Surinam
Surinam coopération avec la Guyane donc
avec la Guyane la l'actualité territal
de Guyane il y a un certain nombre de
problèmes le premier est celui de
l'orpayage illégal donc qui est un sujet
complexe dans lequel autant je pense
sous le contrôle de mon collègue les
progrès ont été sensibles avec le Brésil
autant avec le avec le le Surinam et
comme l' dit d'ailleurs la première
ministre quand elle s'est rendue à la
frontière le le 31 janvier elle a dit
voilà on manque un peu de volonté
politique du côté surinamé pour faire
cesser c'est ce cet porpyage illégal
avec l'usage du mercure qui est
extrêmement polluant et pénalisant pour
les populations le donc le Surina nous
avons un accord de coopération policière
qui a été ratifié qui est entré en
vigueur en 2017 je donc théoriquement on
peut coopérer c'est un des obstacles à
cette coopération et le fait que nous
avons un accord sur la frontière sur le
le fleuve Moroni sur les les disons les
2/ers de la frontière qui n'est pas
encore ratifié donc on a malgré tous nos
nos toutes les assurances qui ont été
données par le le président santoki y
compris au président de la République
donc on est et un dernier tiers à
négocier donc on est sur une euh quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre du euh qui
n'est pas satisfaisant euh qui suppose
une volonté politique partagée du côté
du Surinam au-delà des assurances euh
qui nous sont données et d'autre part
euh euh dernière chose je pense on on
la le le Surinam pays de de 700 700000
habitants
euh est confronté à une situation
politique intérieure disons assez
complexe avec une majorité fragile
menacée d'explosion donc ce qui fait que
le Parlement pour différentes raisons
euh ne se saisit pas de de cette de
cette question de la ratification de de
l'accord de frontières donc je pense que
là-dessus euh c'est un pays avec lequel
on a un partenariat avec qu'on souhaite
développer mais on a euh une frustration
euh persistante en ce qui concerne le la
coopération transfrontalière nous
souhaitons mettre en place des
patrouilles mixtes euh et l'autre
dernier point de de disons
de de frustration également c'est la
question des des migrants illégaux qui
transitent par le Surinam en particulier
euh à partir d'Haïti donc il y a un
certain n de de charter donc on nous
explique que c'est du regroupement
familial donc la réalité c'est que les
les demandes d'asile ont été ont été
multiplié par TR en Guyane en
particulier des haïtien donc on a un
vrai problème qui a été résolu à
diverses périodes ce problème s'est posé
au Nicaragua le Nicaragua estant un pays
de transit de migrants je pense que les
Américains ont mis bon ordre en intimant
au compagnie aériennees de C ce genre de
pratique euh qui aliment peut-être à
dessin l'immigration clandestine vers
les États-Unis donc on a nous on la
Guyane pays très vaste assez peu peuplé
relativement et avec une frontière assez
longue euh et confronté à et perméable à
ce à ce genre de à ce genre de menace
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à votre
question oui une une dernière question
on a beaucoup parlé
du contrôle des flux de narcotiques et
mais on a relativement peu parlé du
contrôle du produit du du narcotique et
du trafic c'est grosso modo 400
milliards de dollars dans le monde c'est
6 milliards de dollars en France et
régulièrement nous
apprenons qu'un certain nombre de pays
ont refusé une extradition alors même
que nous savions et qui avait été
condamné un certain nombre de
personnes avec des décisions qui sont
définitives et qui doivent être
exécutées donc qui justifient une
extradition et ces extraditions ont
échoué au même titre que nous apprenons
qu'un certain nombre de pays sont assez
peu regardant sur des acquisitions
d'actifs notamment d'actifs immobiliers
avec le produit de ces de ce trafic
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques indications sur ce que fait le
ministère des Affaires
étrangères pour lutter contre ce
phénomène bon je je je vois monsieur le
rapporteur dans dans ce que vous dites
une peut-être une allusion aux émir Arab
uni voilà voilà absolument donc voilà
alors effectivement on ne pouvait pas
terminer ce ce panel sans évoquer cette
situation après la partie consacrée à la
caractérisation des flux et des sources
il faut évidemment que nous abordions
cette question de la coopération
policière et judiciaire et nous avons
effectivement une situation
insatisfaisante avec les Émirats arabes
unis et notamment l'émirats de
Dubaï alors
euh nous avons comme vous le savez sans
doute une trentaine de cibles
prioritaires euh aux Émirats arabes unis
à Dubaï euh cible prioritaire définie
comme des des trafiquants français euh
dont nous savons qu'ils sont aux Émirats
arabes unis à Dubaï et dont nous
demandons euh l'extradition du moins
l'arrestation euh et aucune de ces
cibles prioritaires euh n'a été extradée
vers la France au cours des dernières
années euh quand bien même certains ont
fait l'objet d'arrestation il y a eu des
articles de presse qui ont été consacrés
à cette
question cette situation n'est pas
satisfaisante que faisons-nous pour y
répondre d'abord nous le disons
régulièrement aux autorités de l'émirat
de Dubaï mais aussi au gouvernement
fédéral au plus haut niveau de façon
très concrète à chaque fois que nous
avons un entretien politique qui est
prévu avec un interlocuteur émirien de
haut niveau cette question est mise à
l'agenda dans des termes très directs et
très
francs deuxième chose on lit parfois que
les difficultés d'obtenir les
extraditions sont lié au fait que nous
ne serions pas suffisamment diligents
dans la mise en œuvre des procédures au
fin
d'extradition là aussi je voudrais
assurer les membres de la de cette
commission que nous faisons nous
administration française c'est-à-dire
que ça vaut pour le ministère de la
Justice comme pour le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et nos ambassades
là-bas notre ambassad aux émir Arab unis
nous faisons preuve de la plus extrême
diligence dans l'exécution des
commissions rogatoire
international notamment au fin
d'extradition euh comme vous le savez
sans doute il y a une convention
bilatérale qui a été établie avec les
Émirats arabes unis au fin d'extradition
qui fixe des délais assez contraint pour
obtenir ces extraditions
euh il faut notamment que le tous les
documents soient parvenus dans un délai
de 40 jours le délai commençant à courir
à la date d'arrestation ce délai court
très très vite naturellement mais nous
faisons tout
euh nous mettons tout en œuvre pour que
ce délai soit respecté et que toutes les
pièces soi fourni aux autorités
émiriennes pour obtenir cette
extradition dans les délais fixés on Ste
à un certain nombre de difficultés euh
et donc euh pour résoudre ces
difficultés qu'avons-nous fait euh le
premier stade de difficulté c'était des
difficultés de coopération
policière que nous avions auparavant
pour obtenir l'arrestation de ces cibles
prioritaires et donc nous avons déployé
aux Émirats en mars 2022 euh un officier
de liaison sous la forme d'un officier
de police je crois euh qui a été
spécifiquement placé à l'ambassade de
France à Abu Dhabi pour améliorer la
coopération policière avec les autorités
de police des Émirats arabes unis et de
fait on a obtenu une une une
amélioration de la coopération
policière avec les services d'ailleurs
de de de l'ofaste avec les autorités des
Émirats arabes unis qui s'est traduite
par un certain donc cette amélioration
s'est traduite par un certain nombre
d'arrestations bon et le deuxième
obstacle auquel nous heurtons toujours
aujourd'hui c'est un obstacle judiciaire
c'est-à-dire que maintenant que ces
personnes de nationalité française sont
arrêtées nous ne parvenons pas à obtenir
leur extradition alors que faisons-nous
nous allons déployer un magistrat de
liaison pour améliorer la coopération
judiciaire et l'exécution de ces de ces
demandes d'extradition ce magistrat de
liaison d'abord on en a fait la demande
le ministère de la Justice l'a accordé
le processus de recrutement est achevé
le mag magistrat est identifié et il
sera déployé dans un délai là dans les
semaines qui viennent je dirais un délai
de 6 à 8 semaines on espère qu'il sera
déployé d'ici mars pourquoi faire pour
améliorer la
discussion avec les autorités
judiciaires en déployant un magistrat
là-bas donc c'est la façon que nous
trouvons pour pour essayer de remédier à
cette situation ce
défaut je je je je n'est pas du tout lié
à une difficulté du côté de
l'administration française qui transmet
toutes les pièces mais à des difficultés
alors un rigorisme extrême dans
l'interprétation des délais par la
partie émirienne un rigorisme extrême
dans les pièces qui sont demandées par
la partie émirienne sans que nous
sachions véritablement bien interpréter
ces difficultés puisque ce qu'on dit
aussi régulièrement aux autorités
émiriennes c'est que elles-mêmes n'ont
pas intérêt à garder ces criminels sur
leur territoire et à leur offrir une
sorte d'impunité de fait et c'est ce que
nous leur c'est ce que nous leur disons
ça ne contrib pas à la réputation non
plus des Émirats arabes unis et donc
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi nous
avons tant de difficultés à obtenir ces
extraditions et j'espère que le
magistrat de Lison qui arrivera dans
quelques semaines à Aboud Dhabi nous
permettra non seulement de mieux
comprendre mais surtout d'obtenir de
meilleurs
résultats alors sur unecision qui a été
prise par la justice à Dubaï et il y a
un arrêt ou jugement je sais pas qui a
été rendu j'imagine qu'il y a un
appel la décision pratiquement et
formellement elle a été examinée par le
ministère des Affaires étrangères par le
ministère de la justice en France qui
est-ce qui est chargé et qui pourrait
nous dire sur quel point de droit ces
extraditions ont été refusé c'est les
affaires étrangères la
justice c'est plutôt c'est plutôt la
justice alors
nous bon dans dans le dans l'organisme
de dans le dans le dans le processus de
transmission des commission rogatoire
internationale des mandats d'arrêt et
cetera ça transite par le ministère des
Affaires étrangères naturellement mais
le la source c'est c'est la justice
c'est le ministère de la Justice qui euh
qui euh bah les qui fait qui fait
l'interface avec les juridiction
françaises euh
donc mais souvent c'est c'est enfin à ma
connaissance ce ne sont même pas
desdcitions qui sont motivées c'est
simplement nous n'avons pas obtenu les
les documents dans les délais et donc
nous C cet individu a été
relâché alors relâcher mais avec
confiscation du passeport souvent
c'est-à-dire que ces individus ne
peuvent pas quitter le territoire voilà
localiser confiscation du passeport cont
tenu des des moyens technologiques des
émiriens on est à peu près sûr qu'il
contont pas le territoire émirien
toujours est-il que ils échappe à la
justice française qui est le
problème je je voudrais pas faire preuve
de ne pas paraître discours 3 en ne
répondant pas à la question de du
sénateur
Kadic j'ai peu de chose à dire à vrai
dire car vous avez dit l'essentiel hélas
avec avec le Venezuela comme vous le
savez notre coopération est quand même
extrêmement limitée alors s'agissant
maintenant de démanteler des filières
entières d' repaillage et de blanchiment
vous imaginez qu'on est très loin de
pouvoir aboutir à ce résultat d'autant
plus que euh euh il y a sans doute des
factions armées euh et euh qui euh qui
sont évidemment inclus là-dedans donc
c'est extrêmement difficile déjà même
pour les véézuéliens qui seraient
honnêtes qui sont honnêtes il y en a euh
de de d'arriver à démanteler leur propre
réseau alors avec nous ce serait
extrêmement compliqué euh sur les
précurseurs chimiques et le Pérou
évidemment je partage totalement votre
analyse comme je l'ai dit nous avons un
placé un expert technique à
internationale à la devvida mais la
devvida c'est un organisme plutôt
interministériel au Pérou il est vrai
que les moyens euh qui sont nécessaires
pour démanteler en fait euh ces euh ces
ces réseaux nécessitent beaucoup plus de
ressources humaines alors les Américains
eux ont placé des agents il y a un
nombre beaucoup plus important d'agents
d'adea dans un autre organisme qui
s'appelle la dirando au au Pérou et là
qui fait beaucoup plus je dirais de de
coopération opérationnelle euh enfin je
voudrais terminer par l'Uruguay euh
puisque vous avez posé cette question
euh près de 10 ans après l'adoption de
la loi de 2013 il faut reconnaître que
la légalisation du cannabis récréatif ne
fait pas de débat en Uruguay euh sans
pour autant avoir permis d'atteindre les
objectifs sanitaires et sécuritaires qui
avaient été fixés par les les pouvoirs
publics en fait la régulation du marché
il y a à peu près 30 à 40 % des
consommateurs qui s'approvisionnent sur
le marché légal donc il en reste
forcément encore qui ne s'approvisionne
pas sur ce marché légal n'a pas permis à
l'état de réellement mieux contrôler la
consommation de cas cannabis en
l'absence de donn fiable il n'a pas mis
fin aux autres trafics eu alors la
légalisation est pourtant présentée par
les promoteurs comme la seule voie
possible et les parlementaires
Uruguayens réfléchissent même à à
autoriser le tourisme
cannabic mais plus généralement le débat
sur le cannabis c'est passé au second
plan depuis plusieurs années en Uruguay
face au développement de la du transit
de cocaïne et il semble effectivement
assez difficile de tirer des conclusions
sur les interactions entre les entre les
deux
phénomènes il nous reste à vous
remercier pour votre disponibilité la
qualité des échanges et puis l'ampleur
des informations que vous nous avez
transmises on attend un petit
écrit a des questionnaires écrits qui
complètent cette audition et vous
remercions une nouvelle fois pour cette
disponib
ité